Governor DeSantis has narrowed in on
what I think is his most potent attack
against Donald Trump and this is the
attack did great for three years but
when he turned the country over to fauci
in March of 2020 that destroyed millions
of people's lives and in Florida we were
one of the few that stood up cut Against
the Grain took incoming fire from media
bureaucracy the left even a lot of
Republicans had schools open preserved
businesses and so Florida since covid
has outperformed virtually any state in
the country when you look at all these
significant metrics this is a potent
argument and the other thing that
DeSantis is going to do you can see
DeSantis is a very smart guy the other
thing DeSantis is going to try to do is
he's going to try to take positions to
the right of Donald Trump and he is
going to Hope and his campaign is going
to hope that Trump takes that bait and
and takes positions to the left of Ron
DeSantis